hello everyone welcome back to the
channel today we'll be building out a
distributed logging and metrics platform
which is definitely something that you
need when you have a massive application
and constantly have to dump out a lot of
data now as a person who dumps out a lot
of data myself very frequently multiple
times a day in fact I know a thing or
two about building these types of
platforms so let's go ahead and get into
it let's get started all right so like I
mentioned today we're going to be
talking about building out a platform to
take a bunch of distributed metrics to
capture a bunch of distributed logs and
ultimately have them for future analysis
and Playback so this is kind of abstract
question uh but you know we'll get
through it and uh for those of you who
like me are very tired right now all
I'll have to say is keep pushing uh like
I said I know a thing or two about
taking dumps and uh keeping pushing is
the way to do it so let's get into this
thing first off we've got a few
different types of data that we want to
keep track of we've just got logs from
our servers right you know here's an
example of one k uped into Jordan come
over later baby that happens sometimes
number two is structured data right
imagine we have some object you know
let's say our server is in Java we have
some Java object and we manage to
serialize it in a way that you know
keeps the fields of the object around
and then we can go ahead and uh put that
in some sort of database so we have a
you know like a DM request from Megan
the fox to Jordan again these get
published pretty frequently and then the
third thing is going to be some sort of
metric right so maybe this is time
windowed data so for example today
Jordan has had 22 DMS from girls that's
accurate it's definitely not the other
way around that Jordan has dm'd 22
different girls and then finally we also
have unstructured data in which we have
some sort of payload uh where basically
you know uh maybe we're getting this
from another source that's not actually
our application and we're just
forwarding it to persist it for later
and so maybe we get um an Instagram DM
from Sydney Sweeney to Jordan yeah that
happens as well cool so let's talk about
some more formalized problem
requirements the general gist here is
that we're going to have a ton of volume
of data coming in from all of our
different application servers if this is
a big server or a big Service uh we're
probably going to be horizontally
scaling out our service and as a result
of that uh we've got many different uh
origins of data and so you want to be
able to store all of that and be able to
analyze it later this could be for the
purposes of debugging or just for our
business analysts to get a better grip
on who our customers are so again we
might have some window data which could
be formatted As Time series we might
have just text logs from servers which
are good for debugging and error
handling we can have some structured
data where structured data is like
taking an object from your program and
just throwing it into a database so you
can eventually read it back in later and
also unstructured data which ideally we
would like to eventually turn into some
form structured data I did also put over
here enrichable data in the sense that
you know if you know the structure of
your data let's say that structure has a
user ID involved and now all of a sudden
we want to make a join with some user ID
from an existing database in order to
enrich our data to make it easier to
query in the
future cool so the first thing that
we're going to talk about is our
generalizable data sync so because this
is going to be some massive application
that we're getting metrics for we're
going to be publishing a lot of data and
at the end of the day if you're
publishing that much data publishing it
directly to a server that's going to
communic uh to you know try and
basically do things with that is not
always the best idea the reason being
that you might end up taking it down
perhaps for whatever reason you have um
you know a super high volume of logs for
one second it's possible that a bunch of
synchronous HTTP requests to that server
where the server has to process them do
some computation and then forward them
elsewhere it's not going to happen fast
enough and ideally you just want to dump
them to one place forget about them and
then everything else will happen down
the line so for our purposes probably
what we want to do is put them in some
intermediary place like Kafka the reason
I say Kafka is one it is a log based
broker meaning that these messages are
actually durable and persistent we can
can replicate them uh we can partition
if need be which is great and of course
that also enables us to use something
like a stateful consumer like flank or
spark streaming which not only ensures
that every single one of our messages is
going to be processed at least once but
it also allows us to cash data from
other places if we want to do some sort
of stream enrichment in the future so
again uh Flink or spark streaming is
going to be very useful uh but we'll
talk about that more in a little
bit cool so the first thing that we're
going to talk about which we could
potentially do in our Flint consumer is
data aggregation so I've touched upon
this many different times on this
channel but for posterity I will do it
once more the first type of data
aggregation that we can do is a tumbling
window right so this would be like
discrete intervals from you know 12:00
to 12:10 so every 10 minutes we make a
new tumbling window and this is always
going to be on that perfect interval of
like starting at the zeroth second of
the zeroth minute and then the zeroth
second of the 10 10th minute and so on
and so you know if we have a point like
12:15 we basically just cut off the five
we you say oh this buckets into the 1210
bucket and then throw it right over here
so hopefully that's easy enough the next
aspect of this is the hopping window
where the hopping window would really be
like okay well now we have 20 minute
windows so same thing as before however
now they can overlap so technically this
guy is overlapping with this guy and so
the way that we would represent that is
actually just by you know doing the same
thing as before right where we aggregate
our tumbling windows and then we just
combine the results together so this guy
over here is really just the combination
of two tumbling Windows one to the left
half and one for the right half so
hopefully that makes enough sense and
then you would kind of do the same exact
thing as before where you attribute one
point to a bucket and then ultimately
when we want the results for a given
hopping window we just aggregate the two
buckets that we care about cool the last
aspect of this is going to be the
sliding window the sliding window is
again another thing that I've touched
about plenty on this channel uh in order
to implement it you basically just use a
link list where as events comes in uh
you put them at the end of that link
list and so that way you know let's say
we have a 20 minute sliding window over
here my last event is 12:19 let's say
it's 12:23 and another event comes in at
12:23 oh wait a second now it's been 20
minutes we have to remove any events at
the front of the link list that are too
old well 12:00 is outside of our sliding
window let's go ahead and get rid of
that so that's going to be constantly
changing the point is there's no set
start and end time of the sliding window
uh it's just as time is going on we just
take the last 20 minutes for example
cool so the question is now we've
aggregated oursel a bunch of metrics
that are indexed by time right because
as I you know uh say every 5 minutes now
I have another data point that I have to
put into some sort of database right I
don't want to store it in my Flink
consumer forever generally speaking we
want to keep that data in memory or
maybe in a rock DB index on Flink but uh
Flink is not meant to be a database it
is meant to allow you to do some
computation and ultimately put that data
in some database so here is our time
series sync uh the reason I suggest
using a Time series database is fourfold
so first of all the main thing to note
that a Time series database is useful
for is this kind of concept of the
hypertable and chunk table design so the
reason that an index in a Time series
database is called a hyper table is
because it's made out of these small
little chunk tables and chunk tables are
basically just an abstraction for a
bunch of mini indexes so every single
index is actually just a combination of
a date and a source or some time range
and a source so for example if we have a
few different servers uh you know one
server would be a source and then the
date that it's publishing that data that
data would actually be uh the time stamp
associated with that and so you know
maybe I would say today for Server a is
going to be one chunk table uh yesterday
for Server a is another chunk table and
so by actually representing these things
not as all just one table but as a bunch
of little mini tables we get a few
different benefits the first thing is
that the whole table for that source and
date range is easier to cache in memory
uh this is useful for us because
typically we only want one source and
date range combination at a time so if
we can just throw that whole little
index in memory we can read from it
super quickly the next thing is that
this LSM tree per table is going to be
smaller and this is good because again
typically we're only writing to like one
of them at a time and so if we have a
smaller LSM tree because there are
literally fewer rights in there that
means that uh you know the logarithmic
time complexity relative to the size of
the LSM tree is going to be a little bit
faster another thing that we could even
do is you know if we said to oursel oh
we're going to be ordering this data by
timestamp you know 12:00
12:01 and we know that it's coming in by
timestamp right so I always know that
the 1201 data time is going to come in
after the 12:00 I don't necessarily even
need an LSM tree because the LSM tree is
there to actually order the incoming
data however if I know that my data is
already coming in ordered perhaps I
don't even need an LSM tree I could just
use a length list like before and then
I'm good to go when the length list gets
big enough then I go and flush it to an
SS
table hopefully that makes sense the
next thing is that uh if something is in
the same chunk table it should probably
be on the same partition so it just
makes it super easy to figure out what
your part uh partitioning schema is
which is nice and then the final thing
is that deletes are also going to be a
lot faster right so let's say you know
it's been a while since this data has
been published I want to drop it keep in
mind that in your typical LSM tree plus
SS table based index a delete is
actually the same exact thing as a right
the reason being that you want to
publish a tombstone because you don't
actually know where the right lives so
you publish a tombstone first to your uh
LSM table and then eventually you flush
the tombstone to your SS
table and then after that's flushed uh
through the compaction phase it'll
eventually get mer merged in and if you
see a tombstone in one ss table you can
delete the original value of the key in
another SS table but the idea is that's
expensive right we know that all rights
take a certain amount of time to happen
it would just be a lot better if we
wanted to bulk delete data that we could
actually just do so by getting rid of
the chunk table if it's its own
individual table all we basically have
to do is say hey drop the table we don't
care whereas you know if I wanted to
delete a large amount of data on a
normal SS table uh based database then I
would basically have to go contend with
existing rights that are coming in at
the same time which would be not
ideal cool the next aspect of this
problem that I wanted to talk about a
little bit was text logs so like I
mentioned we get a bunch of these text
logs it's literally just a bunch of
strings not too hard to deal with but we
do want to treat them in certain ways so
there are a couple of use cases that are
pretty typical when you're dealing with
text logs the first is that you want to
look at the whole log file right so
basically whatever the current run is of
This Server uh you know it's started up
uh we want to see all of the logs for
that run and so in that case we can
again use a Time series database right
we can just model it as the time the log
was published and then the actual string
uh associated with that log so that
could be
nice and then additionally another thing
that we can do or that people like to
commonly do when dealing with logs is
actually going to be searching for
specific terms right typically there are
a lot of logs logs can get spammy and so
it's nice to have some search bar that
you can just type into and quickly find
all the lines that you need
and so what we can actually do here if
there are enough of these logs is store
them in a distributed search index so
the idea of a search index as we've
covered many times before is to use
something like an inverted Index right
where you'll actually take the key term
that someone might search for and then
provide all of the line IDs in the log
that are relevant and so ideally you
know we would be able to put a few
different logs in one partition of our
inverted index uh but the general idea
is that we definitely want to make sure
that Within within one server's logs and
within the Run of that server that's
going to be on the same partition so you
know today my logs from server a are
probably all going to be in the same
partition of the inverted index uh so
that I can quickly search all of those
uh the one downside of that is that you
know say we want to search historical
logs for a server right let's say I've
seen some error and I want to know what
day that error started uh now
potentially I do have to search you know
10 different partitions if I want to
search back for 10 days so ideally you
can fit more than just one day into a
single partition of the inverted search
index uh but if you can't then you are
going to have to run a distributed query
where you aggregate the results of
multiple days cool so the next thing to
do is talk about structured data so like
I mentioned occasionally we just have
objects in our application that we want
to be able to store and serialize and
then potentially one day even read them
back into our application and
deserialize them but ideally you know
just have them there for analytical
purposes and then query them using SQL
or something like that that so imagine
you know we have Jordan shopping cart we
want to put that in a database somewhere
so I can analyze what my customers were
actually looking to buy and so that's
just a list of some custom objects that
I created called item cool so the idea
is we do already know our schema right
so uh that's why it's structured data
and so as a result we can perform a
bunch of optimizations if we have our
schema we can actually list out that
schema in a certain encoding framework
like protocol buffers uh Thrift or abro
and all of these things have a couple of
pretty big advantages which is that
because the data is structured and
because we know the structure of the
data we can basically avoid passing out
all of the field names in advance so for
example you know if my data model is
cart list of
item I actually don't have to include
the word cart in there uh for me to
parse because whatever it is that's
receiving this data also has access to
the schema can see the list of items and
then say Oh wait clearly that's what was
in the card so again this is going to
reduce the amount of data that we have
to send both over the network and also
store in
Kafka cool so just to you know quickly
draw that out to make sure that
everyone's on the same page here let's
imagine that I have some uh data that I
want to call a person right and a person
has a name and a size in inches I'll let
you uh interpret what that field means
on your own but the gist is let's say I
was sending this via Proto buff right so
the way the Proto buff Works would be
that a name is field number one and size
and inches is field number two and so
what I would actually send over Kafka is
You Know Field one is Jordan and field
two is 13 in again interpret that how
you will so the gist is that instead of
having to write name here which is a
much uh bigger amount of data to send
than just sending the number one I only
have to send an individual number so it
becomes quite a bit more Compact and
then the same goes over here I have to
write only two instead of size in inches
which is a big string so again now I
send this data I send my Proto it goes
over Kafka and it hits Flink so how does
Flink actually know how to deserialize
it right now it just sees one and two
what does that mean well ideally we
would have some way of actually sharing
the schema between our
publisher and between our
consumer and the way that we would do
that typically is via some schema
registry where in the schema registry it
is basically a centralized repository of
our Proto schema or our AOS schema or
our Thrift schema and then Flink can
actually read that in and if we wanted
to get even more efficient than that
Flink could actually cash it because it
is of course a stateful consumer there's
no reason that it can't have knowledge
of those schemas locally cool of course
in comparison if we weren't to use one
of these uh Frameworks and we just
instead decided to use Json naively now
of course we would have to include the
word name we would have to include the
word size and inches and that's a bunch
of extra bytes that we don't necessarily
need to send however when it comes to
something like unstructured data you
don't really have a choice the issue is
that you know let's say I'm running a
server and I'm reading from a bunch of
different apis from other companies I
don't know if their API is going to
change I don't have access to their
Proto Buffs I don't have access to their
averos schema or their Thrift schema or
whatever it is that they're using and so
as a result I'm kind of just flying in
the dark and I pretty much just have to
materialize this data using Json and
then down the line we can go ahead and
normalize that to make it easier for us
to query cool so the idea here is we're
going to need to do some sort of
postprocessing so again we've got some
sort of
publisher that data is going to go over
Kafka it's completely unstructured so
it's probably going to be
Json we get it in Flink over here in
Flink we can take a few different
messages and aggregate them to one file
some sort of txt file if that's what it
needs to be because Json is in text so
we push that file over to
Hadoop the reason being that we now want
to run some sort of spark job so our
spark job our ETL job is now going to
take this file it's going to convert it
into actual understandable data that we
can read perhaps a parket file perhaps
something along those lines and then
sync it somewhere else or it could sync
it back to htfs it could sync it to htfs
it could sync it to S3 it can syn it to
a variety of data warehouses but the
idea is we're going to have to do some
sort of transformation and order to do
that we probably need to run some
arbitrary code via a spark job cool so
the idea there is we want to take our
unstructured data and make it
structured so the question is now that
we've actually kind of run this big
batch job or maybe we just had
structured data in the first place where
do we actually want to put it well if
you recall from our systems Design
Concepts videos the idea is when we're
doing analytical queries generally
speaking we want to use something called
a column oriented data format so column
oriented storage is basically the
following you know let's say say have
column a column B column C and then you
know Row 1 2 3 4 5 and six normally uh
most typical oltp databases which are
the ones that we would use in our
application for user interactions are
going to store the data like so where
each row actually has better data
locality because typically when we read
a row we want the whole thing right you
know if I'm reading someone's profile in
Facebook I want that whole profile I
don't want everyone's profile and and
everyone's username I just want one
person's profile however when doing
analytical queries typically we're more
so just interested in a few fields of
the table at once and all of the values
of them or a large subset of the values
so let's say this was all the emails and
I wanted to figure out how many new
emails signed up on a given day it would
be a lot better to just have better data
locality on the column and not have to
read in all of these other columns
because that's just going to slow me
down now I have to read more data but if
these guys are literally stored next to
one another on disk it's faster and I
only have to read a smaller subset of
data now in reality uh most databases
that are doing column oriented storage
will actually use something known as a
Pax format which is really a hybrid
where it's like you kind of do column
oriented storage here and then you do it
again here and then you do it again here
and then you do it again here uh but
again I'm not going to go too into that
so again this is great for good data
locality for analytical
databases cool and so what do we
actually do in terms of implementing
some column oriented storage well if we
wanted to we could just export our data
to park files so par another topic that
I've talked about plenty on this channel
but the idea is a it's column oriented B
it does a lot of encoding and
compression in order to ensure that uh
we're not storing too much data and that
we can actually speed up our reads
potentially as a result of said
compression and then also what's another
big thing to actually speed up our reads
is by basically storing a bunch of
metadata in the header of the file which
is called predicate pushdown which
basically tells tells us you know maybe
the range of the values in that column
uh perhaps something like the Min and
the Max uh which is the range I'm dumb
perhaps the average and so the gist is
there that that's going to allow us to
speed up our query because we can
basically look at a massive chunk of
values within a column and say actually
uh don't go ahead and read this one we
don't even need to so the question is
now we have all these raw parquet files
where should we actually put them to
quickly do analytical queries and these
days I would say there are two main
metas per se of how you're going to read
parket so the first one which seems to
be more popular at the moment is just
storing them all in Amazon S3 or some
sort of cloud storage provider so the
idea there is that S3 is super cheap
because you know your your dis space is
not scaling linearly with your compute
S3 is basically you know just a bunch of
hard drives I would effectively think of
it as and so as a result it's always
going to be cheaper because you don't
need to add a bunch of CPUs at the same
time the issue with S3 is now if we want
to run a query over this data we
actually have to load those S3 files
into a distributed processing uh Center
like had doop and then you know run some
sort of spark job in order to actually
process the files now of course this is
going to take extra time because we have
to load the files over the network for
what it's worth in my independent
research it seems that uh you know
modern technology makes it such that you
know Network tends to not be the
bottleneck for these things and it's
more so CPU and so now you have all
these Cloud native G uh databases
gaining a lot of popularity uh snowflake
data brick stuff like that and so again
that's option number one one option
number two uh which may be more
expensive depending on uh you know just
your specific company or whatever
application you're running is to just
store all those files into dupe and now
you get better data locality when
actually trying to query them again you
know for whatever reason you are already
running aop cluster and you have a bunch
of extra disc space maybe this is going
to be the better option for you so paret
files are nice in the sense that you
know they're really good for
generalizable queries and keep in mind
that the way that I've kind of proposed
making these paret uh files is that
they're inherently partitioned by time
right because you know say it's a bunch
of structured data coming into flank and
we're aggregating that into a bunch of
par files or it's a bunch of
unstructured data that goes into Hadoop
and then we turn it into parket files
regardless we're going to basically be
doing that on some time interval and so
the park files that we create are going
to be by time I'm not going to have any
data from one year ago in a PAR file
that I created today but sometimes you
may want to have that right let say
there was some arbitrary field that you
know 90% of your queries are going to be
relying on to uh basically get their
analytical results right maybe for
example uh you're like an e-commerce
site and you know that the majority of
your queries are only going to be over
one vendor ID at a time it would be a
lot better then if you could partition
your data in a little bit of a different
way and so potentially then rather than
just syncing them to you know all of
these kind of naive parket files maybe
what you would be better off doing is is
actually using a data warehouse so there
are a lot of common data warehouses
these days like I mentioned snowflake
already there's Google big query Amazon
red shift but the idea there is that a
lot of these guys are going to support
uh some sort of custom partitioning
schema or some sort of custom indexing
schema and by actually syncing the data
to a system like that they can be a
little bit smarter about partitioning
rather than just naively partitioning by
time and so again if that is a use case
that you need this could be potentially
more useful for you and that you know to
to clarify that's not to say necessarily
that you know you couldn't make this
happen Yourself by just setting up an
hbas instance on Hadoop and using the
cluster key but uh I don't know it does
seem that these Cloud native uh data
warehouses are getting quite popular
cool and so the last element of this
problem that I wanted to talk about was
going to be stream enrichment so like I
mentioned sometimes you have some sort
of database you know let's imagine this
is like a user info
table and now you have all these uh user
clicks
coming in with a user
ID and the user info table also has a
user
ID and so every time that a user click
comes into your Flint consumer you would
like to enrich it with some of the user
data that is corresponding so ideally we
want to be doing this in our stateful
consumer is it possible that we actually
just read directly from the database
absolutely however that's kind of slow
because now we have to make an
additional Network call every time a new
user user click comes in what would be a
lot better is if we could actually just
cach the database data in our Flint
consumer and that way we can do our
joins even faster now of course this is
very very easy to do if our user info
table is small if it's not small we're
probably going to have to do some sort
of partitioning of our Flink indexes you
know make another one here and the way
that we would want to partition them is
probably going to be on that user ID
field so that now we only have to
basically read in a chunk of our data as
necessary
I'm going to use this opportunity to say
that there is an ambulance in my
background and I'm looking at it try to
get through but it is just not happening
so that was a good opportunity for me to
stall and cough anyways as this guy
drives away let's talk about the final
aspect of this video which is just going
to be bringing it all together cool so
like I mentioned we've got a server as
our data source and the first thing that
we're going to be doing is publishing
daaa the reason being it's possible that
we have some sort of bursty messages
here and maybe our consumer server can't
handle all of those at once regardless
we are going to be publishing lots of
different things to Kafka it could be
some sort of structured message using
abro Thrift or protuff or it could be
unstructured and use something like Json
or XML the next thing that's going to
happen is we are going to have our
stateful consumer actually consume this
data so here I did use spark streaming
the reason being that it actually mini
batches these messages which I do feel
is probably a little bit more efficient
than and trying to read them all as they
come in like Flink wood but it doesn't
really matter I think either would be
fine and again that might perform
windowing if it's time series data it
might perform enrichment if we want to
enrich the data so right over here that
could come from this database it could
go through uh Kafka via change data
capture basically as changes get made to
the database uh it sends them over to
Kafka and then Kafka can send them over
back to our Flink or spark streaming
node and then the last aspect of this
that we might actually want to do is
just create parket files right typically
you don't want to create a file with
just one row you want to aggregate some
data sync it into a file and then you
know put that into either S3 or Hadoop
or whever you end up putting so let's
look at all of our possible syncs the
first one we discussed is S3 probably
super cheap if we just have a bunch of
files of data and still relatively fast
these days but maybe not as fast as hdfs
where you can do the data computation
locally otherwise you'd have to read it
in from S3 and then run a spark job
there cool the next aspect of things is
going to be a data warehouse like I
mentioned this is going to be nice if uh
you want to partition your data by
anything other than just like the time
that it came in uh if you want to be
doing some sort of less naive
partitioning the next aspect is
something like an inverted search index
or you know if we're being realistic
probably elastic
search which is going to allow us to
search our logs very quickly if we have
a bunch of them uh it is possible that
we may have to hit a few different part
itions of elastic search but ideally uh
you know it would still be relatively
fast the last aspect of this problem is
going to be the time series database for
all of those windowed metrics time
series databases are going to allow us
to take advantage of that hypertable and
chunk table design so that we can both
insert and drop data really really
quickly well guys I hope you enjoyed
this video I know super abstract again I
feel like for a problem like this you're
not actually building out anything
concrete but you just want to know the
trade-offs in the event that uh your
interviewer does ask you something a
little bit more concrete and then you
know you've got these five different
solutions at your will have a great
night and uh enjoy your weekend everyone